someone please send me in my dm's a porn
of a guy with his penis wrapped in
cookie dough because they're just gonna
make it for you
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to big man
for the audio listeners who do we have
here
you're gonna try to make me speak in
that place
thank you and then i'm jessica obviously
she's got it it's because she's hosting
that episode i have to cater to yeah the
host you do thank you for following the
leader we are missing
even though
that's true
we're missing gina though
she may or may not have covered there's
no test
and that will verify it right now
we're being cautious because she was in
contact with someone who has to test a
positive that's the reason why she's not
here yeah she wished is that she was
here and she's actually actually in this
house she is in a different room
sleeping probably so if you yell really
loud or listen really hard you might
hear her my hair's snoring
yeah she's being lazy while we're
working
typical gina
today we had we realized that we hadn't
talked about anything sexy in a while
since
way back way back in uh i guess october
november yeah with your indiana bonus
story
um so i found these two articles that
were very similar on two different sides
so the first one was people talking
about things they tried during sex and
ended up hating because of like how
impractical or whatever it was and then
the other article was kinky things
people
ended up actually really loving after
they tried it oh okay so i thought it
was two sides of this yeah two sides of
like doing weird [ __ ] during sex let's
talk about sex baby yeah i suck about
you and me you probably are all the good
things and the bad guys
we're gonna get copyright copyright
strikes just like that
exactly i could already think of the one
about the one that they tried and they
hated because you have one i have one
always it does have to do with the
visual of yours in that article the
visual the shower oh i it is water okay
um it's having sex in a pool yeah
that is like not fun at all okay so
that's a rookie mistake so
i heard it was the first time i tried it
it wasn't fun the second time they're
like oh you got to do use vaseline which
i heard later is really bad for your ph
vaginally but with the vaseline it did
work
oh nice
yeah try it again you can't why don't
you try it with crisco while you're at
it
just try it all over do you think the
oil would work because that's what we
probably it's just oil it just has to be
something water
water repellent that makes sense yeah
but still lubricated right right um you
could try aloe vera
gel yeah that might be more healthy that
makes it like well it's more water-based
but then i feel like maybe i don't know
if you just like lather a bunch on
before you get in maybe it'll help i
don't know just like it would be like
yeah coconut i just don't know about the
idea of putting oil inside of my body
i'm like does it ever come out don't you
eat oil yeah
but i mean like in the vagina oh cause
like i'm like is that my vagina has been
working properly okay we've been good
non-doctors
yeah i'm literally never gonna have sex
in a pool ever since i'm down to try it
again now really with crisco no
coconut oil okay same coconut oil yeah
cause um what's that mexican lard that
they used to lard
what's it called
you should give it a try yeah
so what was the tortillas on the side
some pork lovers or was the experience
was it just uh yeah so like
um it was just so dry like yeah it was
nighttime we went skinny dipping casey
night and like it turned squeaky
yeah it was just like
it was not good
yeah it also made me like feel like i
was like pushing water up in there too
because like we it's not like we like
inserted and then went in the water yeah
yeah
maybe try that maybe try that
you can only
pull out either you know you gotta like
insert get in and then he can only go in
and out like
so the water can't come in pumping water
in there i don't know like i felt even
after i was like man i felt bloated i'm
like is this is it my imagination or did
i really get like a lot of water pumped
in there and then later like just going
to pee or whatever i i had like i gave
birth that i could relate to
if you go down a water slide yes
oh my god this water's like stand up and
it's all like warm water
i'm like can people tell that that just
came out of me no no one can tell
but it feels big enough that
could tell yeah really because you could
feel it's like a different temperature
yeah it got warmed up by being inside
your body oh yeah and then just like the
air and just oh and then yeah because it
was like that squeaky feeling yeah like
because it was so uncomfortable like it
did not last very long at all we're just
like well we tried it like yeah it
didn't work out do you have anything
that you the shower thing like it's just
always water-based yeah yeah it's like
well you think it's these things that
you think are going to be hot like
because
oh yeah exactly and then you get in
there and you're just like oh the water
is my face and like just splashing my
brain like i don't care i will say i did
have shower sticks once that actually
was really good but i think it's because
the water
didn't hit that area so it wasn't
messing with the lubrication it wasn't
messing with the room itself was hot
enough in the shower okay that's the
other thing yeah this is cold you have
to let that hot shower run for long
enough to where the actual bathroom is
steamy like you know when you're in
there and you're like yeah i can't
breathe it's [ __ ] hot it's [ __ ]
like you have to steam up the whole
bathroom and then you have to have a
shower situation where like you can kind
of be in there and maybe get a little
hot water on your back or something but
it's not like yeah in your face you're
like [ __ ] like you can make a shower
situation kind of it just sounds like
too much work but it's just it's but no
it's like it it either like your
bathroom works for that or it doesn't
yeah i think and like i and one time i
do remember having shower sex where i
was like oh [ __ ] i almost actually
almost came in the shower because oh
okay it worked out so well yeah it also
depends on what positions you can get
into exactly because like if you're just
stuck standing it's not very fun well it
worked out for me
yeah well the like dog is standing i
guess so steve and i can't it's like
impossible to do that standing because
he's a foot taller than me and i just
can't bend over and get my butt that
high can you stand on like the two sides
of the toe
maybe with some water
he's holding your a lot of acrobatics
involved i've already been to the
emergency room once with our second page
it's scary yeah
i've been tossed into a nightstand yeah
okay so the moral of stories just don't
even bother in the water i mean you
could try it once and be like well we
tried it water is never hotter we gotta
have something memorable so they can
remember water is never hotter yeah
[ __ ] the water okay so well the first
one on this list is my girlfriend wanted
to try whipped cream in bed but she
bought the chocolate kind
there's chocolate whipped cream i guess
i've never seen it kind of fun but not
great and the sheets told a very
different story from
[Music]
and can you imagine like if you kind of
notice as you're having sex that there's
like brown marks all over them
that's another thing you don't want in
your vagina is sugar yes yeah pro tip
unless you want a raging thrush yeah
don't put anything sugary down there
i did i used food before how'd that go
um what kind of food so it was chocolate
what's with the chocolate yeah and like
it was like uh yeah melted chocolate i
think i can't remember like hershey you
just popped hershey syrup out of the
fridge
i really can't remember if it was
chocolate syrup or whipped cream i don't
know and before she wanted to put
coconut oil down there so she's just
treated this i already know
i just have this hilarious mental image
you know like um the raw cookie dough um
rolls yeah whatever i just imagine like
with all these different ingredients you
like creating a cookie around his penis
and then just like kind of start to eat
the raw cookie dough off of his penis i
could see some injuries there
potential injuries because i might chew
through it like the homemade kind of the
other stuff has preservatives
it has to be vegan yeah
yeah i remember like we were eating
strawberries too or something or i don't
know it was like i'm not hungry when i'm
having sex so i find it just a weird mix
of activities yeah the only thing i'm
ingesting is alcohol yeah i will have a
drink yeah but
yeah food no those are two different
things in my brain yeah same thing yeah
that's why i it was his idea i always
had like i don't like uncomfortability
or anything sticky like yeah it just
seemed like stickiness taking you out
yeah it definitely did take me out of
the moment it was very sticky it was not
very plain and then like you're just
like trying to like make out but then
there's like food in the way and there's
yeah and then you're trying not to get
it on your sheets and stuff yeah that's
exactly
so [ __ ] ocd i'm like this is staining
everything i don't like it or you lay
down plastic
towels even worse yeah ew then it's like
that um what's that movie like americans
like american psycho yeah the whole room
is just covered in plastic yeah it's not
creepy
okay here's another one
my ex-wife wanted me to choke her while
doing doggy style okay so she's leaning
forward and then he's got long arms huh
yeah i guess he's got long hair or she's
maybe she's leaning kind of up back
that's doable she's got a short torso
she's kind of still sitting up back
towards him maybe okay um she refused to
move forward so i wasn't perched on the
edge of the bed i did my best after
about 30 seconds my planted leg slipped
off the bed and my fingers were
interlocked basically he put her in some
sort of wrestling oh my god
i don't know how that worked out but
yeah getting choked maybe just do that
like
she like fell off the bed and choked her
basically like choked her for real oh
[ __ ] i uh i don't like being choked like
the you know the traditional way but i
could see it being hot like maybe there
was like a leash or like a tie or like
something like where like i'm
it's like more of the
humiliation thing then the choking
factor of it you know like they're
pulling on you like you know where they
pull on your hair yeah like pulling on
like a like a tie or like a leash they
scares me because i feel like it would
hurt your um i don't know because i have
yeah things because you're supposed to
like when you choke generally they choke
off from the sides right like you don't
actually push on the front yeah like
voice box or whatever
so like i imagine if there's something
tied completely around your neck like
like maybe a belt or something right and
then as they're pulling that then it's
like oh right it's like choking you in
directions
yeah i don't know something else i don't
know yeah it could definitely end up bad
i'm just thinking of like what sounds
like it would be more of a turn on to me
is
like some sort of leash situation but
the but the shot really kind of the
choking part no i don't like the
checking well i enjoy the choking and i
enjoy that that actual move
is very fun
how does it go down you smell the
choking with the yeah i mean what are
you choking from so he's just like
thrusting like with you like while he's
holding your neck yeah like or like
reaching around because then like also
like you know doggy style you reach
around you feel some titties yeah yeah i
like the
titties you can just move up a little
bit why are you saying this while
pregnant yeah how do you think i got
pregnant
this is the results
no but yeah i mean it's doable it's just
the fact i think the key thing
is the fact that he was at the edge of
the bed is what he said yeah right like
he had so no you have to be in the
center the center of the bed make sure
yourself right proper balance is yes
perhaps make sure even though it might
take you out of the moment just make
sure you're fully planted before yeah
first
i have had a couple of those times
though where like his foot wasn't
solidly on or like his knee then was
like so close to the edge of the bed and
then it slipped and then he's like oh
[ __ ] he like pulled his groin because
he like he like basically did the splits
unintentionally because one knee fell
off you gotta be really limber to have
sex these days
or just make sure you're in the center
of the i don't know how we [ __ ] get
to the edge or to the bottom
how did i get up here
how am i on the ceiling
scary movie can we scooch just a few
across the room
oh my god okay this one chick uh oh no
sorry this is a guy he said uh she
wanted to surprise me by sucking my toes
but i reflexively kicked her in the head
oh my god don't surprise people without
no or any any sexual act yeah exactly
like
at least maybe because but can you
imagine they're like can i suck your
toes
i imagine tim's doctor i'm gonna suck
your toes now is that okay
okay
consent but like asking for consent for
some of the things is just hilarious
yeah can i lick your butt or what if you
want to be okay with you if i suckled on
your toe don't use the word suckle
suck is fine we don't need the l
um what what do you think like do you
like say i like my toes getting sucked
yeah i need to ask consent for the
person to suck them true
my toe to your orifice
to your mouth
guys
how are you not just getting banged
every day jess that's so hot
that's how she how do you know i'm not
yeah that's true everyone has a kink
yeah
i had a do you ever have a anyone that
sucked toes because i had a boyfriend
that sucked toes like all the time well
trying to have them had you've had your
testosterone i don't like it yeah i
don't know either
they have to go for it though like you
can't be like
first of all
they gotta put like half your foot in
their mouth like it's gotta be warm
and then they gotta go in between too
much strollers they can't handle the
drawers they gotta like really commit
that's really ticklish for me like
that's the thing for me where i'm like
it feels nice because it's warm yeah
it's too ticklish yeah i can't handle
that much saliva that's too many toes
that would create too much saliva one
toe's good but one time
[Applause]
but um i get disgusted after the fact
when they try to kiss me
like i don't
whatever
in their mouth hey no well that's their
choice yeah
i agree with you
everything mixes together you need to
just get over it my feet were on the
ground yeah and then you put them in
your mouth and it's just i don't like it
like i was sweating in my socks earlier
like yeah thank you i don't want that in
my mouth like you wanted okay i'm gonna
judge you i wouldn't picture y'all doing
that like without having kind of done
the priest sex shower like not that
you've been running a marathon all day
yeah i don't do a preset you went to the
grocery store and then you did all this
[ __ ] and then you put
i don't know i feel like if someone's
willing to put it in their mouth then
i'm like okay we'll share that
like you have it in your mouth i can get
it in my life i'll get over it nope no
i'm good yeah i only think about it for
a second i'm like oh that's kind of
nasty
whatever it's in your mouth it's in my
mouth now
i don't i got over the whole like eating
me out and then kissing like kind of
like yeah what about the butthole though
i never had my butthole yeah
well the first time i did i was like
wait
my [ __ ] is in my mouth
it's in your mouth and that's when you
created them all yeah like all right new
rule it's in your mouth that's in my
mouth yeah my bubbles in my mouth your
balls in your mouth
say that my butt holes in my mouth my
bloody leaves my mouth right now but
honestly didn't really taste like
anything it's just like just the thought
of knowing that their tongue touched
your own [ __ ] and then because you
were never gonna lick your own ass no so
you would never think that that's gonna
happen so then like to know
that something went straight from ass to
mouth into your mouth yes
but then you just got to get over it
fecal matter because they're willing to
have it in their mouth and it's like a
team sport
it's a team sport where we have
different uh jobs yeah so like if you
want to choose to do that job i'm not
going to share that job with you
you pick that door it reminds me of your
would you rather is when it's like would
you rather have [ __ ] that tasted like
chocolate chocolate tastes like well i
would take the chocolate even if it
tastes like [ __ ] because knowing that
i'm eating [ __ ] is like
nope no big nope but it's not like real
[ __ ] because there's not much of [ __ ] on
my ass
oh i
like if you take your tongue and you
lick your [ __ ] right and then you you
put it like you make out okay you send
it to a [ __ ] hat yeah
but then if you do the same thing where
you you [ __ ] use your finger and you
wipe your [ __ ]
and
you're telling me you don't think you're
gonna get [ __ ] in that not after a
shower
i don't know i don't know either because
your farts even have i don't know
i don't think [ __ ] just always exists no
matter what i think if you take a shower
and you scrub your [ __ ] oh i don't
like asking you are you like scrubbing
with your finger and no i don't go
inside of my
side of my [ __ ] i'm not a [ __ ]
psychopath
there's definitely wrinkles
no like but you kind of bend over open
up kind of scrape around the general
area you're getting like ninety nine
point nine seven percent an [ __ ]
i i'm with tiff on this one whatever
because did you fart after your shower
yeah
are you using my pre-shower and then
afterwards
don't tell me i have that i don't have
that okay i have a very clean butthole
all the guys that are obsessed with
buttholes say i have a very nice
smelling butthole that's a lot of guys
it's nice so they like they like my
butthole
how big's the sample size
it's pretty large actually
you should know that
you should know are you like me and you
use google or another search engine to
search for all kinds of stuff even
embarrassing stuff maybe sometimes
illegal stuff just out of pure curiosity
i know i do i hear some conspiracy
theories and i start googling that stuff
and you know what sometimes that google
search history is a little embarrassing
and also i don't want to get ads
targeted towards me based off of these
search
results i know most of you are probably
thinking why don't you just use
incognito mode well let me tell you
something incognito mode does not hide
your activity it doesn't matter what
mode you use or how many times you clear
your browsing history your internet
service provider can still see every
single website you've ever visited and
you know what they do they can actually
legally sell your information to add
companies that's why when i'm at home i
never go online without using expressvpn
expressvpn is an app that re-routes your
internet connection through their secure
servers so your isp can't see the sites
you visit and collect your data and sell
it expressvpn also keeps all of your
information secure by encrypting 100 of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available most of the time i
don't even realize i have it on it just
runs seamlessly in the background and
it's so easy to use all you have to do
is tap one button and you're protected
expressvpn is available on all your
devices phones computers even your smart
tv so there's no excuse for you not to
be using it and honestly a lot of you
guys that work remotely from home are
probably used to having a vpn on your
company computer obviously they know why
it's important so maybe you should use
it for your personal information as well
protect your online activity today with
the vpn rated number one by business
insider visit our exclusive link at
expressvpn.com big mood and you can get
an extra three months free on a one year
package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s vpn dot com slash big mood
expressvpn.com
big mood to learn more today's episode
is sponsored by honey the easiest way to
save when you're shopping on your iphone
or computer thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past honey is the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one it finds to
your cart here's how it works when
you're shopping on one of your favorite
sites at checkout the honey button
appears and all you have to do is click
apply coupons you wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons it can find
for that site and if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch the prices
drop now i've been a huge fan of honey
for many years i've used it throughout
time especially with booking trips in
the past but in more recent times i just
used it when i was purchasing some
clothes for my newborn and i saved about
like 20 bucks which is awesome because
then i get to use that money for diapers
because oh my god we're going through so
many diapers now and i get to save money
on diapers too when i shop with honey
because then it'll just pop up and i get
to use the coupon codes on sites and
it's amazing i love it if you don't
already have honey you could be straight
up missing out and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
this show so get honey for free at
joinhoney.com big mood that's join
honey.com
big mood okay let's try to find
something that people wound up actually
liking okay that they didn't think they
would
so i have one
oh yeah you can go into this
you know like how i i've said many times
on the show that i would i like public
sex like yeah like the thought of like
maybe getting caught same and i've never
gotten caught but maybe that's why i had
a good experience with it yeah but if
you got actually embarrassed
steve will never do it um but i the
first time it was because we didn't have
a choice like you don't have you're a
teenager you don't have anywhere to go
so you're like okay i guess we'll go to
costco parking lot and like some pillows
or whatever and then i just like i
didn't think i was gonna like it because
it's like uncomfortable but then it's
like oh like the thought of possibly
getting caught like added to the
sexiness of it and i it made me way more
turned on because you're so close to the
line of like it could absolutely be
ruined if like a cop yes like she walks
up and then one time a cop off gives you
a point after we were done yeah like so
we were cuddling in the front seat and
fully clothed but it was like right
after and a cop like knocked on our
window and
he was like what are you guys doing i'm
like oh we were just having a peaceful
moment
peaceful moment teenagers saying a
beautiful moment come on we were by the
ocean like are you guys high with
this he was confused
and so he looked like put the flashlight
in our eyes and he's like all right yeah
he's like yeah [ __ ] it the windows are
like
like just stop being foggy yeah
exactly like the last little bit of fog
like finally cleaning from the window i
could have sworn it smelled like sex in
here
what is that why does why does sex have
a smell i know that's so interesting
what's it called yeah perspiration
breath and skin yeah yeah
breath sweat and a little bit of vagina
and then oh yeah smell common vagina
juices yeah
mixing together create sex smells that's
so weird what a perfume i remember i had
sex in public in austin several times
and every time i drive no not recently
this was before i moved to california so
this was like six or seven years ago or
no even longer it was like 2012.
10 years ago we were just talking about
2012 was 10 years
that was a long time ago so i had sex
outside by the lake or the river i guess
the river that runs like
below downtown austin and also in like
parking garages around that so sometimes
like when i pass by those places i'm
like let's
yeah kind of a little tingle
yeah remember the fun of it that's true
that's so true every time you walk by it
you're like i had sex okay costco
that's fun i like that i have one that i
think you'll love nikki okay
um a guy asked me if he could spit in my
mouth
because i'm very submissive in bed
honestly it was a huge turn on i'm
offended can you believe that someone
enjoyed getting spit in their mouth from
a dude because of this
thing you could connect to the
submissive thing no you can relate to
that part yes
yeah but
nope it takes me right out i'm like
nope
what if she was like you're gonna like
this [ __ ]
i think i would let a girl spit in my
mouth really but not a guy oh cheers and
i'm only really sexually attracted to
men that's the part of their dictionary
yeah i'm like a girl i dream of his
mouth i trust a girl's mouth to not be
disgusting
one time my ex-boyfriend um did the
thing i'm pretty sure he probably saw it
from porn where he went
right oh my vagina they do that right
before they do that i was like i need to
put clothes on right now i need shower
like right now it's disgusting i don't
know why you would and he got
embarrassed and i in hindsight i was
like i shouldn't have called about that
that hard because it's like supposed to
be a safe spot but i didn't know he was
going to do that and it was like well
you're not surprised he didn't he didn't
like worry about you being safe spot
comfortable either
he just immediately [ __ ] hocked a
loogie on your vagina it was yeah
exactly that's what it felt like
that's what we call porn sick ladies and
gentlemen no we can't [ __ ] read the
room at all just [ __ ] doing crazy
[ __ ] don't surprise people in the
bedroom that's rule number one yeah i
don't know let's see if we can find one
that actually sounds interesting though
um of a kinky thing that someone
actually enjoyed oh god this one's gonna
be crazy okay
my ex-girlfriend and i were browsing
porn together and we stumbled upon a
lesbian pee scene okay
we decided to watch it and then part way
through she jokingly suggested that she
should pee on me oh so this is a girl
peeing on her boyfriend okay we were
already in a dumb sub bdsm king dynamic
where she was the dominant one so i sort
of joked back that she should and we
both sort of said huh let's try it
so she drank more water and then we made
our way out into the shower like i
should have prepared
she needed some more pee yeah i got on
my knees and she proceeded to pee
on my tits oh these are two girls
a lesbian yeah well i was quick guys
he has tits
okay yeah i was like wait okay so it was
two lesbians watching lesbian porn okay
but then they stumbled upon the pc and
they decided to try it and they enjoyed
it i will say i would let a girl pee up
you know i'm kidding
i think you would trust girls yeah
[Laughter]
um i will say and i don't i've never
have never admitted this please please
don't judge me this is a vulnerable
moment okay but i have i i don't know if
i would ever want to do it in real life
just like how i like gang banging
there's a lot of yeah i don't think i
would actually like
a gangbang
um where i got turned on by the idea
of like you know like the submissive
part again where after a guy's finished
and he comes in you like he just starts
peeing
inside yeah
peeing inside of you just like as like
uh yeah like you're interesting it's
impossible i don't know
but i wouldn't want it to actually
happen yeah but the thought of being
just so like he just owns me that much
is like
what about being outside of you yeah
that's probably more doable well then i
don't know peeing inside of you he's not
healthy
casey do you think you would be able to
pee right after coming inside of a
vagina
not really
how long would it take for you to be
able to pee you'd have to go down first
to pee and then by then it'll slip out
now sometimes guys do like pee in the
boat and they have a boner in the
morning
but that's before you come for your yeah
so after you come you need like some
time some space before you can actually
pee again okay do you think you could
pee before coming well inside
could you please oh
before coming let me try it
i'm not saying you could try it we could
try it
now you've got me wondering if they
could i just scientifically yeah because
i know that with them peeing with the
boners probably and this is like a porn
that i saw i used to read literatica
do you know have you ever been a
literature i was kind of a nerd um so
it's like sex stories oh online and like
i didn't watch porn or anything but i
would read like sex stories so they were
talking about like submissives yeah they
talked about that
how come i've never really heard that
like i always think about peeing like on
your body or something well i have had i
have heard of a story of like this guy
losing his virginity so it's like first
time sex and he thought he was coming
but he ended up peeing
oh i did hear about that oh huh i think
the first time i had an orgasm when i
was like younger like a kind of like a
preteen or whatever i thought that i was
gonna pee too because you just never
right i actually had that sensation like
i i did pee
you did yeah like i remember uh
masturbating in the closet because i was
like so like ooh privacy yeah and yeah
like i thought i was coming but i was
actually i was like this smells like p i
peed
is that what squirting is no
but no this one time it was a lot like i
just my bladder emptied and i was like
oh okay
and your mom's like who peed in the
closet
you're like oh no i always had towels
laid out because i told you i was
like i would [ __ ] make a mess so i'm
like okay the towels are laid out did it
catch up what's going on
now you know if you have a girl and then
in 10 years or 14 years there's like
towels and clothes oh
god he passed down the sport
i it's a boy
oh that's better
that's why i intentionally had my
my son at 11
learn how to do his own laundry because
i'm like i'm not doing this
we're not going through this
so he does his own laundry he was 11.
that's nice he's been doing his own
laundry some of these are so gross i
didn't want to say them out loud
those are the ones that don't work or do
work these are the ones that people
actually like okay
yeah i want to know okay
um i dated i'm trying to figure out who
this is to okay i think this is a man
and a woman because they're talking
about cream pies okay
i dated a woman who always wanted to
make a man eat her cream pie okay
yeah so that's when so he came
oh okay i mean you see why i'm having
trouble even reading some of these but
those biscuit party things are a thing
biscuit party what is the biscuit party
yeah and then the last person has to eat
it why did you come out of biscuit
though i don't [ __ ] know they're guys
gravy and gravy
okay
oh my god honestly whataburger has this
like
butter honey butter biscuit and it make
it looks like [ __ ] on the menu
so that makes sense a dude came up with
that marketing yeah that's something
he's like honey butter used to do that
whatever it looks like
so they they are biscuit party players
yeah gross okay so anyway this story i
dated a woman who always wanted a man
eat her make a man eat her cream pie
when we tried it it was my first time
coming in her before i even got to enjoy
it she put both hands on my shoulders
and pushed me down
i licked up every drop oh my god i loved
it so much i was instantly hard and we
had sex this sounds like fake oh this
sounds like one of those
just [ __ ] nasty
he got turned on by eating his own [ __ ]
that he came inside her and then they
[ __ ] again i don't think he really ate
it i think he it was probably just
falling out and he was like going down
on him he drank every drop he said
i looked up every drop and he did say
that but i feel like he's exaggerating
that's why it sounds fake to me because
it's like why are you like
maybe
maybe he um he had already tried it
before and he was like oh it's no big
deal
i've tried i feel like almost every
guy's like no i'm not gonna get my own
calm what the [ __ ] you know yeah
i don't know i mean i don't know i could
i guess i could kind of
a little bit relate like being so
[ __ ] turned on like with yourself you
just do whatever you're just [ __ ]
like every drop i don't know huh
um
because i'm not even excited to drink up
every drop of [ __ ] like and i'm drinking
that's not mine
yeah that's weird is that cannibalism
just kidding it's like peeing in a cup
and drinking it
[Applause]
oh god okay i want to try to go back to
one that they didn't like
go back easier
it was easier
this one i feel like is i could have
wrote this one uh once my boyfriend
requested that i let him titty [ __ ] me i
tried but they are two oh yeah and it
was very awkward i could never do that
again
trying to [ __ ] squeeze together with
all of your might
your tiny little two inches of titties
it doesn't even cover half the dick no
even um so i had this a d cup in high
school uh i don't know what stuff [ __ ] i
know
i don't know
and then it was to see and then it was
now it's at like between a b and a c but
i have like too much space like there's
just a cleavage space too like in that
yeah like it's never been tight together
yeah even if i push them together it
just doesn't there's too much of a gap
and they look like they're fighting for
their left over trying to get there the
nipples are like jesus
yeah so
no i'm not a fan of titty [ __ ] i'm
jealous though
i mean it's like whatever i guess it's
just like a hand job but with you it is
it's just like
like you just see the dick head
all i picture is a guy twerking on your
belly button
that's so [ __ ] funny
you're basically twerking over her belly
button it's either that or i have to
move
up and down
yeah okay like that's gonna become a gif
oh no
no no no no
it's okay i think that audience is
probably not paying yeah they're not
here they're not like we have real boobs
to
make gypsy yeah what was it was there
something that said somebody sometimes
like basically guys [ __ ] is just a
twerking yeah
like for doggy style and stuff like
that's definitely just twerking
i don't know if that's what twerking is
but yeah that's [ __ ] hilarious do you
uh your cats ever like hump each other
hump each other
yeah
yeah okay so like my two boy cats are
just in love like they love each other
and um they have like a mating ritual
that they do every day every day yeah
every day and uh joe's the submissive
one frank they're joan franklin and joe
will make this guttural noise like he'll
just be like
wrong
and then frankly will come out of
nowhere and be like
then
flops over and then franklin like does
this on his stomach and then he just
starts thrusting above him
and there's no contact thrust yeah he's
thrust like it looks like there's he's
twerking
can you please send me a video of that
yeah that is hilarious every day they do
every day i mean i don't catch it every
day because i yeah you know i'm not
always right next to them but
like if around
his back um he's like he flops on his
own to his side okay and then franklin
like kind of massages his belly
and then just thrusts over him and
joseph's like
yeah daddy
okay that's interesting my two girl dogs
help each other all the time really
hilarious looking i've never seen a girl
hump yeah
she looks so dumb like
dogs look dumb as [ __ ] when they're
trying to [ __ ] are they so stupid yeah
they're both fixed and they're both
girls and they both grow up together
yeah so they're incestuous females same
like
they're not related they're not related
yeah mine aren't related either well
mine are related yeah but they don't
like i don't do you ever see them hump
each other like i i have had i have seen
it but that was like before they got
fixed um so i'm like oh [ __ ] don't
impregnate yeah they're both they're
both fixed yeah but now they're both
males well like i will see
oh i will see one or the other like
they'll take turns on who's dominant
like i i don't know i don't know if
that's normal i knew that [ __ ] cat
joe is a power bottom oh yeah
he loves it he begs for it
we are cats like they don't hump they
just or i don't know they'll just be
like on top of each other but not really
they're like they'll do like dominant
pouncing kind of thing okay
but not humping
this is like full-on like thrusting i
saw the humping before they got fixed
okay that's what i said i'm sure this is
really interesting for everyone like
let us know do your pets do this like i
signed up for a kink episode i want to
hear about dickson vaginas only why are
you talking about cats not cats [ __ ]
[ __ ] excuse me i just thought it was
interesting that the animal kingdom also
has things that it enjoys maybe you
didn't think i was going to enjoy
yeah here's what we got um well this one
i was i was kind of flipping through
them this one is like not something that
you should try this is just a sex fail
okay but i thought it was okay it was
kind of funny this guy said he was
trying to hold in a fart while getting
head
it came out
it came out loud and a little
high-pitched
i felt so bad for her but she couldn't
stop laughing i took her out to dinner
instead all in all i guess it worked out
oh geez yeah that's funny i don't i yeah
i'm trying to think like have i ever had
to hold in a fart well someone if i did
i would just be like i would i would
just bring them back up like i wouldn't
like if i'm like oh i feel a fart coming
i'm not going to just be like let's see
what happens
because i like to watch the world
you know like i would be like i don't
know you can come back up you know start
kissing me or something else like get
away or let me just adjust i wouldn't
tell them no i wouldn't say that what if
it came out though and it's like
it was a queef
before they even injured themselves a
guy farted while we were having sex
before but i didn't even notice he kind
of got up like i didn't hear it and just
like slowly started so he just kind of
stopped got up and went
oh my god
i was like that's weird i was like
okay
what that was that would not be awesome
he sat back and like let the ceiling fan
carry the rest of it away he was kind of
like and he like sat back and then just
said he's done no oh my god he was kept
going and he was like i was like i'm
gonna pretend like that didn't happen
yeah something most things like that you
gotta just like pretend like it out
yeah
i can't help but point out funny [ __ ]
yeah like and you have to i have to or
like when a cat comes up and smells your
butthole oh we kicked the cats out every
time yeah i don't know we don't let them
in close the door they just start
scratching the door so
no our cats respect our private time
that's nice just a couple times
franklin's trying to come right in the
middle during it like wow what's
happening
between oh because he's so
overprotective of you
he's like how can i do this too
you know how he copies steve and gives
you kisses yeah
does he try to copy you and hump you no
he never has tried to hug me
thank god that you know he only humps
joe he's very loyal
that's cute so online shopping isn't
slowing down anytime soon my question to
you is is your business ready to keep up
the pace okay with shipstation you never
have to worry about shipping ever again
you can just make the switch to a
solution that handles all of your
shipping needs quickly affordably and
painlessly you save time by funneling
all your orders into one simple
interface no matter where you're selling
so if you're selling on amazon ebay etsy
your own website facebook you know
there's like a billion different sites
that you have to list your products on
and it can get overwhelming trying to
keep up of all the orders from all of
the different sites well that's where
ship station comes in ship station is
kind of like a hub for you to keep track
of all of your orders you can save your
sanity knowing that your orders are
handled and that you're getting the best
rates your small business can actually
access the same discounted rates usually
reserved for fortune 500 companies and
that's really cool so no wonder 98 of
companies that use shipstation for a
year keep using it for as long as
they're in business it's that good i
personally
love using it for any time i've ever had
like sold a quantity of products whether
that be stickers that i made with my
cricut and sold on etsy or my jewelry
line kittens and coffee which i list
them multiple places shopify facebook
instagram and it just puts all the
orders all in one place all into one
software really like the ease of use
with that ship more in less time just
use our code big mood to get a 60 day
free trial that's two months free of no
hassle stress free shipping just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in big
mood that's shipstation.com enter offer
code big mood make ship happen if you
had to choose between a random product
off the shelf or a prescription
treatment that's personalized and custom
blended to help you reach your goals
wouldn't you just pick the personalized
one that's why custom rx treatment from
rhoderm was created it's personalized
prescription skin care that's designed
with dermatologists to help you reach
your goals like getting clearer smoother
healthier skin all you have to do is
complete a 10 minute online visit to
share your concerns like acne fine lines
and wrinkles or dark spots plus some
insight into your lifestyle general
health and medical history the visit is
free and i love that you can do it
without leaving your home if appropriate
a u.s licensed health care professional
will prescribe a custom prescription
treatment that makes sense for your skin
made with a blend of dermatologist
selected ingredients tailored to your
needs right now new members will receive
a 30-day trial of custom rx treatment
plus rho derms hydrating cleanser and
protecting spf lotion for just five
dollars guys when you go to rowderm.com
forward slash big mood shipping is free
and you'll get free and unlimited
follow-ups with your healthcare provider
to support you throughout your skincare
journey if you're prescribed get your
first month of custom rx treatment plus
rhoderm's hydrating cleanser and
protecting spf lotion for just five
dollars go to rowderm.com forward slash
big mood
rowderm.com
big mood there's some a couple more that
are like things they tried that they
didn't like this one says candy
underwear it's all fun and games until
you bite a piece off and this stretchy
string snap something it shouldn't
those are like those little yeah candy
well some of them are like the the
melting mouth ones yeah there's a fruit
roll there's a fruit roll-up style
and then there's also the ones that are
just like thongs made out of all those
little teeny tiny yeah
those are not fun when i was a kid i
didn't know obviously you don't know
about all these like kinky things so i
saw edible underwear in a store i was
like
do you remember like in the 90s
bracelets yeah bracelets and the
necklaces that you could eat candy off
of you kids are gonna [ __ ] lose your
mind when you find out about those this
one um was it looked like underwear on
the box and you couldn't see the
underwear
so on the but on the box i don't know if
it was the fruit and or what because it
didn't look like the candy string kind
of
i just thought literally you could eat
underwear oh yeah and i thought that
sounded so good like cotton candy or
something like that
i could eat yeah me too so i thought
that was funny too like before i
realized what it really was yeah oh cool
because spencer's always had that kind
of stuff yeah so innocent as a child oh
so i miss those days i just want to be
able to tell people i can eat my
underwear
like oh yeah no i don't need a snack i
got my underwear yeah
like you get hungry in class you just
break off a piece or the bra what
happens to the rest of it you know he's
slowly
you like get you keep it like attached
still but like you've got to break off a
piece
weird yeah you're such a weird child no
and a weird adult
okay so i'm like this this one article
about the stuff that people liked is
like so gross and dirty it's like
that's why i'm curious about it because
some of the stuff i'm like really people
they're like really excited about you
can't yuck other people's
i'm sure other people aren't gina's cat
has just entered the room oh so cute you
guys can't see him but he's just he's
like he's like did someone talk about
cat hunting
i'm horny i want to hit all the horns
not
fixed oh he's not right or did he just
get no he
got there okay yeah i'm pretty sure gina
fixed her cap he's like anyways
i know
okay here's another one about p i don't
know why there's so many about p but um
this one intrigued me a little bit
um you know okay so i'm gonna insert my
own little piece here
no
so have you ever
thought or used it like a shower head or
something so it's like the water turns
into like a vibrant massager yeah oh
yeah so get in that headspace right here
so um this guy said peeing on my ex's
[ __ ] she had a waterproof vibrator and
she wanted me to pee on her [ __ ] as she
was coming
okay so it was kind of like the same
shower a bad deal except it was pizza
yeah i wouldn't imagine he would have
enough to last long
unless you just had a very full belly
while she was coming though yeah so like
he peed on her [ __ ] as the like shower
while she had a waterproof vibrator
also going at the same time inside oh
but i feel like you would try like she i
honestly think that sounds like i think
you know what it's kind of good yeah
because it's like that's what it was
turning around like the warmth
associated with the
yeah like one spray
yeah it's just one stream that's kind of
creating that vibrating stream of water
but yeah
yeah yeah she had a vibrator yeah yeah
yeah i could relate to that i could see
that working but i'm just
i'm really confused that like how he can
pee on command like that like that's
like no he probably like already had to
pee you know like hold it had sex for
like 30 minutes and you're like [ __ ] i
gotta pee so you'll kind of stop so like
maybe at that point she was like all
right i'm gonna finish
and he was like
are you ready what if i peed on you you
know i like to think about how he's like
was waiting for his cue yeah like just
drink a [ __ ] ton of water before you
have sex yeah you have like a lot of pew
like i like i can't comment on on
command either like to be like yeah now
like i can't as soon as i'm preparing
for the build up like if i try to think
about the fact that it's building up it
goes back down yeah same like i can't i
can't reach that i have to be completely
like brainless to reach the peak hmm i
don't know every time i think about it
yeah maybe you can kind of see her like
getting there maybe there's some
physical cues because like for me like
this is the peak i'll go like this and
like this and like this and like this
and like this and like
and then a lot and then it's just like
i don't know it's so unpredictable yeah
so i'm like good for them for timing it
out yeah
or maybe she knows like the her own
finish move and like she doesn't have as
much because not everyone has the issue
with the pressure of it like sometimes
like well because i i can pretty much
get it when i have a toy like i can
pretty much make it happen yeah right so
like i'm like i've once this but once
this baby comes out we've got like 30
seconds to a minute
okay here's another one that they didn't
like this one says i had an ex who got
mad at me for not knowing how to use a
vibrator on her i was a 20 year old dude
who had never used one before
i really tried to understand what she
wanted me to do and i kept trying to
follow what she was saying but she just
kept getting more and more frustrated
until she was just screaming at me oh
dang
okay wow so i guess if you're gonna
bring toys into the situation teach them
how to use you yeah that's totally a 20
year old exactly that's something i've
always emphasized is like
they can't read minds they have they
don't have a vagina they don't know how
what feels good they all think of
fingering makes everyone come so let's
i think it's because things on camera
look better yeah they just keep doing it
even though that's not really and the
girl is moaning no matter what so yeah
well she's definitely getting paid yeah
you know like money oh yeah money
honey that you're giving me there's oh
my god there's one actually it says
telling a man where my [ __ ] was he was
so sure he knew and every time i moved
his hand he thought i was trying to move
it away from my [ __ ] oh no honey stop no
oh no
poor guy he wouldn't like
guys are too confident about something
yeah it's like they were helping you
this isn't helping your like just lower
the ego who has the clinton who doesn't
yeah
okay who's the one feeling it do your
fingers feel that no it's like no no i
got this i don't know i got this i get
confused too and like how like
it's in the middle like it's in the
center yeah i don't think it's very
visible to me it's it's right there yeah
it's like a hamburger right you're going
for the meat pan yeah why do you go off
to the side don't don't do the bun no do
the meat patty in the middle of the
hamburger it's not hard it's not not
that hard to find i like that i just
think about how his ex was probably like
yeah that's right there you go yeah
yeah everything she's done and then oh
that's good every time we refuse to
correct another woman has to deal with
it so now we need to correct every
[ __ ] time because it's service to
other women it is you're paying it
forward but it only works if they
actually pay attention and listen yeah
because then if they it's like this guy
where it's like no no i got it
they're looking for a [ __ ] they're like
looking for a bone or something like
they they think the pelvic bone is where
it's at but we're like no there's like
meat and stuff on top of the bone like
don't hit the bone it's not the bone
like don't go up the hole yeah hold my
urethra
we're gonna go over
it's just too soft to even tell what
you're feeling for it feels like the tip
of your nose yeah
as i rub my nose right now yeah
yeah in case you guys didn't you just
don't know
that it's too soft to feel what you do
it's actually the same cereal it's
cartilage yeah it's cartilage cartilage
yeah i'm trying to think of like how we
can explain or how we could help but i
think it's really like you probably just
need to spend a day in a non-sexual
manner like spin it out educationally
two or three hours just looking at it
and then just like
getting comfortable with it just the
control panel spend time with it
read the manual yeah like just check it
out because like we each model is very
different too it is yeah that's true
we see it all day long so we're like
yeah it's this is exactly where all day
long i'm saying how could you imagine
looking at it i'm just staring at it
dude i can't see my own you can't see
anything i can't i can't shave like i
can't believe it like i need a mirror
now so you're telling me you have a big
giant bush no girl he got that giant
belly i i have lasered uh down there but
like does the whiskers
shave so i'm just like trying to feel it
in the dark i could see like with a
mirror but it's just not the same it's
too far my eyesight's worse now with
this pregnancy it's a mess reminds me
when we had a blind dinner for your
birthday i had a hair in my food but i'm
like it could be my hair i had to just
keep telling myself it's my hair
because if it's someone else's hair why
can't you use that same logic when
someone licks your butthole and puts it
in your mouth
it's disgusting to some people if it's
other someone else's hair and my food
obviously i don't want to eat it it
depends where it came from too what
about getting you stuck in your mouth
if it's my husband's pube yeah you're
okay with it you just take it like a
champ and you also know
yeah you don't try to like swallow it or
just do it
get rid of it i get stuck in like my
tonsils i have pretty big toss
the worst is when it's stuck between
your tongue and like the very back of
your tongue yeah you're like because you
can't like
you like keep trying to
slide it out from the back and you can't
i feel like i have a phantom hair now
i'm just talking about it
or those little fuzzies that are like
stuck in in your mouth too you're just
like
yeah
every time we start um
the oral behavior okay
every single time there's a fuzzy there
every time um why i don't was probably
lynn from your underwear i don't know
yeah why don't you as a wife lint roll
your goddamn husband's underwear
have you converted to the patriarchy yes
i have as a wife
to lint rolls
why is your husband's dick picking up so
much well so he takes a shower but
his dick is like
those like sticky roll things yeah
because he takes a shower he has to take
a shower like before sex every time like
he's very very clean he put clothes on
and he puts his boxers on after the show
never knew
to go upstairs and there's always like
boxers just they're gonna have cat hair
on it i got an idea
um changes underwear i have an idea you
know those like things in a restaurant
those bottles that people
that chefs will use for like oil or
whatever yeah like just get it those
clear plastic bottles with like the the
tip like just like just rinse the dick a
little bit before oh
some holy water on it just just have
that like ketchup bottle full of water
and your bed stand and then just no
it'll it won't
it'll stream out like a like a small oil
stream of water okay
and you can clean the lentils just have
them surrounded and take a squeegee and
then
just have him saran wrap his dick so
there's no lint getting on the shower
yeah it's nice and fresh yeah fresh seal
yeah unwrapping the saran wrap off the
date could be a hot experience it's
pretty then you won't be eating every
time
i feel like they're going to try this
now yeah i kind of feel like we will and
i won't tell you i still want to wrap
i don't know what it is but in my head i
have this image of like a very thick
cookie dough
and then she takes it off the dick and
then
when you pull it off it's now in the
shape of a cup he can come in the cookie
dough cup and then you can eat it no
milk and cookies it's milk but then you
bake it yeah and then you eat it it's
like frosting gross top it off with a la
mode with some ice cream not a biscuit
party it's a cookie dough party party
it's a cookie dough penis there's got to
be i could not have possibly thought
that up there because you know what's
that rule whatever oh yeah roll 42 46 or
37 or something that's all wrong with
numbers
i don't know so i feel like there has to
be a porn uh someone in the comments
please go fact check me because i don't
want to do it myself i don't want to
[ __ ] up my search history she refuses to
believe she's original so i want to see
if there's already some sort of porn
where a guy has had his penis wrapped in
raw cookie dough and then i don't know
what happens after that
i don't even
you're not baking there's just
something's going to happen with the
course that's wrapped up
stupid yeah it's just cooking i want a
penis
thank you nikki thank you
that's his brainless idea someone please
send me in my dm's a porn of a guy with
his penis wrapped in cookie dough
because they're just gonna make it for
you i'm gonna do that too
so many dms
i just now i need to see what would
happen or like what we could do
no don't tell her don't bake it
scientifically i want to see
what happens maybe you could just use it
as like like a fleshlight like the raw
cookie dough but i want to see i don't
want to be cold though you know it
doesn't have to be cold cooking i want
to see them eat this cookie dough so
maybe not bake it warm cookie dough is
going to melt off it's too mushy you
can't it'll crumble off and then you can
eat it
as you go and that's cold it's not
little crumbles we've been talking about
this way too long i'm very i'm serious
tiff i really need to see this through
all right the penis
i believe in the rule yeah but uh yeah
some creep in the in my dms please i i
only make yourself useful for one for
one i only want to try it because i
really like cookie dough me too if it
doesn't work
my favorite things together
dick and cookie dough yeah what kind
what kind of chocolate chip absolutely
chocolate chip cookie dough i can't even
maybe show you the other kind of cookies
sugar cookie might work yeah
okay i like chocolate chip cookie dough
but without the chocolate chips so sugar
cookie no but like no it's more buttery
the dough is definitely it's brown sugar
yeah yeah
it's just different the brown sugar okay
so there's no brown sugar in it and
sugar cookie yeah okay yeah see i like
that dough yeah i just don't like the
chips the chocolate chips i like it when
uh when the chips are small oh like a
small chicken yeah smells like a baby
cheese yeah it's a little yes
okay let me see if i can find uh
something else and we can get off of the
oh my god i just saw something if you
had the mini chocolate chips so it would
definitely look like pubes on your dick
like anything like that
mold
okay yeah starting to picture the let's
get some some don't use chocolate chip
cookie dough use the sugar cookie dough
for the dick
okay we'll work that out we'll workshop
it yeah we'll workshop it we'll work
that i'll get with the creeps in my dms
later
um so this person is saying uh something
that they actually liked was using ice
cubes
oh yeah i've heard this yeah i've tried
ice cubes and then looking i've tried it
on the nipples and stuff no just on the
on the [ __ ] oh that's cold i know yeah
and then but that's actually like
nipples well so it's like the cold of
the ice cube and then the warmth of
their tongue is like oh like that hot
icy hot yeah like it feels even more
warm because i didn't try it with
someone i did it myself because i
started like the very first point i ever
saw
the very first porn that i ever saw it
was like they were using ice cubes and
she was just like pushing it in and
pushing it out and i was like what is
that like why are you saying that yeah
yeah so then i i just tried it by myself
in that closet that that closet
has seen something sixteen-year-old tiff
closet imagine your own children's
closet
yeah so then i i was like wait i
literally feel absolutely nothing like
nothing pleasurable at all like maybe if
you have like a big huge
like ice cream in the shape of a dildo
but then also the coldness is cold too
it's great it literally just numbs you
yeah it numbs you and then
you don't feel even when the tongue was
there i'm like it's still not hot enough
to make up for help
you know like when a guy will drink a
drink of something cold and yeah kiss
him and then his mouth feels cold and
you're like okay yeah like it's not like
and i feel like it it would like make
your body kind of
tighten up too like you want to be hot
and loose yes tight and like freaking
very loose that's what all guys
let's see
um let's find
one more on this side which is the stuff
that they liked okay one woman this is
more choking stuff one woman i was with
in my college days told me to choke her
my hands are huge and her neck was small
so i hesitantly obliged she looked me in
the eyes and said choke me you [ __ ]
i was more irritated than insulted i
obliged and felt her
titan around me we ended up doing more
stuff like slapping spanking and using
ropes i realized through her that i'm
really into rough play hmm i like the
hesitation though that yeah describe
good for you
good for you to be hesitant to be say
that
yeah you know steve said that i'm the
first
person he's been with that he's been
he's felt free enough to like
do it rough because i like ruff and then
he he's like oh this is okay and it like
really like made him go i like ruff too
i didn't really get to explore that ever
yeah
so it's nice to be like sometimes i want
to figure out what you're doing and i
don't know if this is true or not uh but
sometimes i wonder if like once you
cross that line obviously in your
marriage it doesn't count but sometimes
with other people i wonder or
relationships that aren't established
once you go in that direction do they
then kind of just classify you as
something that they've degraded
so will they really respect you as like
a girlfriend or a wife after that i
think that's what that's yeah sometimes
i'm like if this guy feels like
boyfriend material i'll be like oh no no
no i'm like computer you know
that's very interesting and maybe it
depends on the person that's doing the
degrading whether they can
compartmentalize it because that seems
very difficult to do like if i [ __ ] on
your chest you're not going to be my
husband because i mean like
so maybe it's my own like internal or
maybe i should be your husband yeah
maybe it's my own nature
i don't know but i'm like why would you
let me do that
i can't imagine
guys then afterwards being like yeah no
she's for the streets
yeah the person because like i had an ex
that i feel like we had degrading sex
and then i feel like he actually didn't
respect me yeah like it's a threat
but then if steve if you could be
separated you know like we both love it
and then like even in the same session
we'll be like i love you i love you i
love you after and like we like cuddle
and do romantic [ __ ] so
yeah it's uh
different
different mentalities for different
people
yeah it's very interesting there
something to think about maybe don't do
the craziest things with the guys that
you actually like maybe try them with
the guys that you're okay with bouncing
or if you do it with the guys you
actually like and they reciprocate and
then their minds don't change then their
marriage material true
yeah
oh but your mind might change what
you're saying oh you might judge them
that's what she would say is that she
can't get that out of her head yeah
yeah
so i'm wondering if other people are the
same like if i yeah like if we did if we
[ __ ] went to war together yeah i'm
like gonna think about that in your head
you're like i sat on your chest yeah
and then and then to introduce you to
all of my you know future
co-workers and stuff in the back of my
like [ __ ] on his chest
meet john i [ __ ] on his chest see that's
what i think is kinky about it for me is
like i like if we had sex right before
going to like a social event like a nice
sit-down dinner and then like if you
[ __ ] on steve's chest okay i wouldn't do
it but i know but it meant yeah
literally if i [ __ ] on his chest i still
think i could separate it but okay um
it'd be like more clean
he's a very clean person and i don't
think he would enjoy that i don't think
he would like but let's say in this
fantastical world that that was okay for
both of us uh yeah i don't think i think
whatever is in the bedroom stays in the
bedroom for me i don't really think
about it outside the bedroom i wonder if
guys do yeah do you think guys can
separate or do they'll always kind of
like in the back their head be like this
girl's a freak i think they're not a
monolith separated in your head i think
i could separate yeah i think it's so
you'll still respect a girl after doing
some nasty [ __ ] yeah yeah you're staring
at me
i think it's person to person okay yeah
yeah maybe i'm like the bad person who
that judged them after so i'm just
assuming other people i think it's just
the same as the [ __ ] thing like like
you can separate it sure that it's like
he likes your [ __ ] and i can't so
it's just yeah it's not good everything
is really confusing and and not the same
and it i think something like that for
me would carry over like
ew like you made me lick my own [ __ ]
like things that i didn't want really
yeah well yeah if you didn't want to do
it for sure leave us a comment let us
know what things have you tried that you
didn't think we're going to work out and
they did or vice versa i would love to
read them i'm just more curious than
anything like what are people doing like
what are they doing in there because
there's nothing really like more because
it's like to keep exploring is just gets
more disgusting yeah i'm like there's i
i feel like i know all the good things
i'm curious if there's something out
there still that's like a good thing but
i feel like i know all the good things
i'm kind of stuck have you ever tried a
sex swing
no you kind of want to try that open to
them yeah there's things there's things
that are just like i'm curious i'm
curious yeah i'd be down a truck but
then we could also find out that it's
complete ass yeah like oh we did not
enjoy that at all totally yeah i felt
like after a certain point you're like
okay
we do sex pretty much the same way every
time and i like it but i'm open to like
switch things up
spice it up see what happens
yeah have sex in public steve
you're just like constantly throwing
that dagger even though he won't be
listening to this episode
okay no they'll be sending it to him i
know right clips of me being like i
would enjoy being peed on inside
steve would just send back a gift of
that guy that's like
no yes
but okay um somebody like i said dm me
that chocolate chip cookie porn anyways
very important if you enjoyed this
episode give us a thumbs up if you want
subscribe if you want to hear some more
visit our sponsors and the links in the
description follow us on instagram
yes whatever all that other [ __ ] you
know what to do because you hear it from
all the other youtubers um we love you
guys smash that like button
[ __ ] smash it all over that like
button's mouth yeah call your [ __ ]
anyways all right thanks guys
[Music]
you